hello Arizona my name is Greg Alva
I'm John and I'm Uncle Sam ah Kisan is
here shooting his last video with us
this might not be the last upload though
I like to make things confusing in the
intros Shrek Ragnarok
what is this you say thor ragnarok
official trailer style of Shrek cuz
everybody loves a wreck everyone knows
these trailer mixes ah and this is by
dark blender actually who was actually
very supportive of the reactor reaction
cause and does some really good stuff
previously a reaction caused but not
just that he did the Deadpool and Ferris
Bueller's Day Off mix I like it check
out his channel
[Laughter]
Oh
nice okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
new stopper here now to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so according to go team
[Music]
at the old date
[Applause]
what were you the god of again No
[Applause]
what is saying you know just a couple of
hotheaded fools
yeah say fire raging fire that was
really good
oh my goodness wow I have a statement I
have a statement I have a statement to
make
look I've seen plenty of trailer mixes
trailer re cuts weird trailers over
whole bunch of these is a trailer at it
Ellen tell him that is the best one I
have ever seen
that's the best one I've ever read three
Elvis stamp of improve my stamp my
opinion matters most nice thoughts
you're whining because it's animation
it's easier to do something like you
know a lot of times we do the
live-action ones it's like when you do
like a weird trailer Valley John it's
like a lot of crazy answer so you do the
trailer re cuts lines with Lambs it's a
rom-com you can't really like change the
dialogue or confine but because it's
animated you could change the dialogue
around he didn't just stick to one Shrek
movie he did a lot of the franchise
which was really clever to use Matt's a
lot there's a lot of Shrek what did she
go to make sure you got the right good
and didn't even sounded like that it was
actually he paid attention to sync it
really al that's what's most impressive
thing about this is a lot of times it
seems like whoever cut this together
looked like they looked four times where
the mouths wouldn't yeah right and to
scout like that you have to rewatch all
those frames finding scenes to instead
of just like okay in this scene he says
it was like finding the fire where
they're sitting at the fire and they're
doing the whole yeah and
you found the right scene to cut back
and fortunately soon everyone more than
just a moment to use tough man donkey's
voice with blender d'Arthur lander Darth
blender very very popular very very good
he's up and coming he's only four point
three thousand followers no we are one
more point one point whatever well I
just subscribe to you and I'm clicking
the notification bell for you Darth
blender you don't deserve to be as
popular as ah Cassandra the real rejects
because of you it's much harder for
unrest it here is watch that video yeah
I'll talk about it then it is to put one
of these together you know it was a base
and then like jump cuts that takes way
more time the careful careful somebody
might actually take that literally I
hope they do now we then I'll ban you
from the comments cuz YouTube has an
option then we're gonna get a dis track
a dis track that's the new thing on yes
it's not a good popular dis try oh no I
will react thanks I appreciate you
people walk here to see our reaction
yeah I'll just do it what our reaction
well guys subscribe to Darth Blender do
use I feel like I've seen one of this
guy's video I must have it and click the
notification bell for this channel I
subscribe to the real rejects you might
get unsubscribe later down the road dad
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
he's constantly tweeting and
instagramming oh and aqus on is aqus on
from the aqus on channel he is who lives
in japan he's not from japan and he
lives in Japan right now for time I'm
seeing you yesterday or time I'm seeing
you yes
that's rough times
and the sexual chemistry just gets
better and that hot and hot and I would
aside from energy calm the real reaches
become a patron ejected a good day
people subscribe to aqus on thank you I
didn't say that no you did it you got it
covered
yeah subscribed it son